of your single going platinum there on
instagram is there like a wing in your
home for all those things like where
does that all uh to my mom's house
[Music]
yeah i'm lucky if i get any of it really
i got a few things and then you know we
spread them out man and um but majority
of things are at my mom's house but
heartland has no shortage of
award-winning talent florida georgia
lion darius rucker blanco brown breeland
and jimmy allen are all featured on the
outfit many collaborators jimmy allen
were big fans of
and you guys have got to dance with the
stars connection you of course you know
famously being on the show he's going to
be on the show how do you think he's
going to do i think jimmy will be good
man i mean you know jimmy jimmy's got a
great work ethic and as long as he works
hard i haven't seen jimmy dance
i don't know jimmy might have some type
of ballroom yesterday before so it could
be different you know what i'm saying i
strictly jumped out of the hood in st
louis and tried the two-step so it's
it's hard to believe it's been over 20
years since nellie's breakout album
country grammar made the rapper a
household name
[Music]
so you know we could talk about all the
accolades in the world right but
sometimes the hardest people to impress
are your own family your kids think
you're cool
i think they appreciate what i've been
able to do a little bit more now when
they were younger i think only they were
impressed that i knew biowow
that was the biggest thing to me you
know what they're saying like it hadn't
mattered but i was so both of them put
together it didn't matter you don't
understand all they knew was that yeah
yeah yeah yeah whatever but uh
where's bow wow